what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
the son of Superman is like the best
thing coming out of BC rebirth right now
like it really is it's the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth the reason why
is because this story is so fun it's
some of the most fun I've ever had
reading a comic book in in like any form
or fashion because like it focuses
almost entirely on Jonathan Kent and
that's something that we haven't really
had yet right I mean we've had stories
where he's been like alongside Superman
and it's kind of cool because we get to
learn about the Superman mythos through
the eyes of his son you know they say by
the costume anywheres and how you know
the blue and the red costume is designed
to inspire hope that kind of things the
black costume was designed to reflect
where Superman was if he was operating
in the shadows but it's always been
Jonathan alongside Superman that's one
of reasons why I why people are looking
so forward to a super Sun which by the
way most guys already have a super Suns
is the best thing coming out of DC
rebirth right now it's insanely good I
read issue number one and I was like oh
my god this is amazing
it's so cool Damian Wayne is amazing in
any of it you know what this story is
it's really kind of funny because it
picks up with Jonathan kid like watching
scary movies right and like he's eating
ice cream he's just having like a great
time themselves because the question as
we can tell like Superman's go on Lois
Lane is out of town we don't really know
where they are like we're just kind of
lets you assume that they're there on
their date night or something along
those lines we don't really know but
dinners friend Cathy rings the doorbell
and scares the absolute hell out of them
put by the way I've been down that road
like it might be only one who will like
go through and turn off all the lights
in each room leading up to like your
bedroom and then like you turn off the
lights in your bedroom and then just
like race to your bed before Jackson and
you guys I do that I do that I'm not
ashamed to admit it there's no shame in
my game I'm not ashamed to admit it 32
years old and and I still do that don't
judge me
don't even think about judging me so
anyway the cool thing about this is that
again this is just kind of one of these
circumstances where Tomasi plays it fast
and loose with us right I mean over the
course of this tour we're gonna have to
ask ourselves is it their imaginations
running away with them or are things
actually happening and that's why it's
so cool but what kind of cross that
bridge when we get to what we find out
so the reason why Cathy's here is
because her cow Bessie had basically you
know wondered out though the fence had
opened up or basically just one reason
or another
Bessie got away and the result is that
her grandfather went to go look for
Bessie the cow and just having really
reported back since we've been gone for
a couple hours now of course this is one
of those funny little situations because
it's just like it's flimsy at best you
know it's just one of those flimsy
little pages the reason they give us the
story but it's the cool thing about it
is it's just a reason to give us the
story
I don't care why Bessie the cow got out
I'm just happy to see a story Bob
Jonathan Kim but of course once they
make their way I guess kind of following
the tracks of Bessie and the traction of
our grandfather they end up running into
dead man swamp this is kind of the cool
thing is because we've seen dead man
swamp before right I mean we saw a dead
man swamp earlier in college but it was
in the daytime and as we all know the
monsters come out at night I mean that's
just how it is like monsters always come
at a night hence the reason why you're
always safer turning off the lights in
the room that you're leaving instead of
turning off the light in the room while
you're there because then the monsters
will get you so the idea here is that
once they make their way into our kind
of poking around there's suddenly this
giant shadow man in the distance so this
is why I say we kind of have to ask the
question is it really their imaginations
because once they take off into the
swamp then crazy things start to happen
this giant shadow man is you know looks
like looks like a legit monster but when
it comes to people hallucinating one
person hallucinating something it's fear
to people is an actual thing and so it's
just like okay like there's an actual
monster chasing them I mean I'd be
hard-pressed to believe there was for
loosening the same thing at the same
time but the funny thing about this too
is remember this play Jonathan is just a
little kid and that's why it works so
well because please think about this and
we're like well Jonathan can do so much
Superman like why did you just grab
Kathy and they just fly away well sure
if you were Superman he would if he was
Superman he would just fly away but he's
not he's a little boy and as you know
when we're kids our imaginations run
wild that's one of the greatest aspects
of being a kid but one of the most
terrifying aspects of being a kid when
you're a kid the world is your oyster
you can dream up these incredible
flights to fancy and allow your dreams
to sort of take you on these wild
adventures and get caught up in the
situation so the bad thing is that your
imagination begins to seize control and
then you start to realize that sometimes
your imagination is evil like sometimes
it's bad that you turned your
imagination is just bad and it just
makes makes you see bad things but this
is when I say that this is this is kind
of where the lines being blurred because
as they're making their way through
deadman swamp suddenly they're grabbing
onto these tree branches that are
massive in size they're being chased by
these owls that are twice their size
they're jumping on turtles that are four
times their size and so it's like okay
either very shrinking or things are
getting bigger and that's why I say it's
really kind of a funny situation because
it's the question that we have to ask
it's something happening here is it
really just like dead man swamp is just
this crazy thing and they're
hallucinations or running wild or is
there something really going on in the
swamp now of course with jobs they can't
able to tap into a few of his powers
here and there of course he uses his
x-ray vision to discover a house and
they end up traveling to it but that's
what I did also want to focus on here
keep in mind when it comes to Jonathan
he does not have full control of his
faculties when it comes to his powers
you can't just fly he can't just use his
heat vision
it usually responds to emotion that's
one of the crazy things about it is
because in a heightened state like this
his powers may sort of run awry but it's
not something that he can just readily
do but the funny thing is once they get
inside this house well then the house
starts moving the house starts rocking
back and forth the ground begins
disappearing under their feet as they're
running up the stairs again we get these
crazy situations on force they
eventually stumble across the best
unocal and there are two questions that
have to be asked here Betsy what is your
problem and - why is Betsy in a house
like Wyatt best you leave them on this
wild goose chase and I want to know why
Betsy's in the house because this is
this is ridiculous we then of course
best you start like stands on our hind
legs move you know starts mooing blowing
out Sammy's just it's all these crazy
things that are happening around them
then of course this 50-foot monster
makes his presence known ripping the top
off the house so suddenly they basically
got to take off down a well you know
really just kind of keep themselves safe
or hiding down the well hoping the
monster will pass and that's what makes
this so cool it's because this is just
an adorable moment you've got this kid
with would basically powers that will
one day manifest to the point that he
will be you know a God among gods but
then you look at him and he's just like
hiding out in the well because he's like
are is the monster gone is it is it gone
like it's still there like it's just
this whole area since a little moment
with this character you know and again
of course you know we eventually see the
grandfather of caddy popping up and like
most of what the world's going on with
you kids we kind of get this
half-hearted explanation of well you
know you guys can't go into that Manso
because it emits these gases that cause
hallucination so it's kind of Tomasi and
the guys saying hey look you know it's
just one of these fun little adventurous
things you know with little kids with a
thorough imagination runs wild and their
imagination is compounded by
hallucinations caused by the gases are
gases in the swamp and so on and so
forth and so of course you basically
have you know the
and father Kathy taking her back home
and Jonathan Ken heading back to his
home but then when we end up having uh
you know Clark Kent when we have our
Superman and Lois Lane returned home
checking on their son to make sure he's
safe we end up finding out there is
actually something out there everything
that Jonathan experienced was real
someone out there basically had the
ability to manipulate the reality around
him I was only one person that I could
think of that could do that without
being said guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you guys are new
here too common to explain make sure you
guys with the sub button become part of
the report if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
this is just a fun little story that's
really all this is I mean it's not that
to be taken too seriously it's like
we're these little filler issues that we
get for those you guys are new to comic
books whenever there are story arcs that
end up getting launched will usually see
like filler issues that are thrown in
here and there between like major story
arcs and what that does is it gives the
writers a reprieve it gives them a
chance to not go for like one story or
to the next it gives them a chance to
sort of relax and the regain their
bearings and they kind of chill out for
a little while it just kind of give them
a chance to basically wind down but the
other half of this is of course as we
know reborn is going to be the next
Superman story so this is really fun
because it's just kind of a great way to
segue because keep in mind with DC
rebirth you know it was one thing when
we were starting off DC rebirth because
it was like hey guys here's the
adventure here's the fun here's the joy
and everything but now we're getting
down to crunch time you know now we're
getting down to brass tacks --is and
we're getting to the point where the
stories are going to start getting a
little more serious we're going to start
getting a little more intense the fun
will still be there but some more
serious tones are going to start being
worked into these stories and when that
happens we're going to want to make sure
that we also have these moments of
reprieve these fun little tidbits that
get thrown in these little goodies and
help to sort of offset not really darker
but the more serious tones of the
stories we're going to be seeing them
progress throughout DC reverb but yeah
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]